[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance in kissing
and this is the show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subject so you know
nothing about a trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts
our brilliant guest this week is a
journalist and the author of hired six
months undercover in low-wage Britain
James Bloodworth welcome to trigonometry
thanks it's so good to have you man
before we get into the interview just
tell everybody who you are how are you
where you are what's been your journey
through life to this point so I'm a
journalist and author my journey through
life well I I failed my I failed my
schooling I felt my GCC's that's how
Jefferson works guys yeah but you can
you can all do it and then I went back
to college when I was 23 is like a
mature student College University then
writing was kind of the only thing I was
capable of doing and so then yeah I did
this and and and I enjoy it it's kind of
the one thing that's kind of my passion
but it's also my work as well which is
cool and you kind of opened with a bit
of self-deprecation but the book you've
written is actually incredibly important
and we were just chatting as you got
here about the fact that left or right
and your left wing and we'll get into
that a lot of our viewers keep saying to
us you need to get more left-wing people
on so we're glad you've agreed to come
on having said that I bet they're gonna
stop moaning but it's good to have you
on and as I say I think your book is
incredibly important wherever you are in
the political spectrum because some of
the stuff that you talk about some of
the things that your investigative
journalism uncovered it's very serious
and it's a big problem for society
especially going forward so for anyone
hasn't read your book yet which I'm sure
they'll get after this interview what
tell us what you did what is the book
about what did you do what was the
process so in 20 and of 2015 I was I had
this kind of idea of a book about kind
of low-wage Britain about what was going
on in the
so you cast your mind back to 2015 David
Cameron was Prime Minister he was
talking a lot by you know the economy is
on the well on the rotor recession
recovery after a long recession record
number of people in work etc etc but
behind the scenes that was it was a bit
more disconcerting the picture so there
was a big rise in the number of people
on zero hours contracts there were a lot
more people working in something that
was being called the gig economy so uber
drivers delivery riders couriers etc and
they were client that little big rise in
self-employment but it was a bit the
world of that was a bit murky and in
terms of whether they're really
self-employed or whether they were
employed by these by these companies and
so I'd done many jobs like that myself
10 years previously so I wanted to kind
of go back a decade later after this big
recession we'd heard and kind of see
what had changed in that in that kind of
world of work and and I didn't feel like
you really got a sense of it from you
know you can do your journalistic kind
of detours for you go on a date you go
for visit some kind of downtrodden town
for like a day you go and hang around
like interviews and factory workers for
a day but I thought like I was really
kind of inspired by coming the immersive
journalism that people like George
Orwell pollito and be Barbara Ehrenreich
had done before
well you fully immerse yourself into
that world and then you can really paint
a true picture of what what it's
actually like to work in those jobs live
in those towns and kind of lead that
lifestyle of the the so-called kind of
pro carrier in there in the British
economy and what did you find
well all sorts of all sorts of things I
mean I was worried a part of me was
worried when I set out to write the book
that it might be you know the first
first place that got a job as an Amazon
warehouse and I thought well you know
this I was worried that my book was
gonna be boring what am I gonna I worked
in a warehouse before when I was younger
and I was worried it kind of is he gonna
be there boring what I might what I'm
gonna write about it but the book but
pretty much wrote itself as soon as I as
soon as I started the work there was so
many kind of shocking things going on
yeah the book essentially wrote itself
so I mean my first job was at Amazon I
kept a diary every day I was working
there and the first day I remember
writing in this diary that the
atmosphere of the Amazon warehouse
had the atmosphere of what I've imagined
a prison would feel like we're sounds
kind of like hyperbole it sounds like it
sounds like I'm exaggerating but it was
you know you were you were given
disciplinaries if you took took days off
sick even with notes from the doctor you
were people were given disappearance for
taking too long going to the toilet you
got to go through airport style security
every time you went on break or every
time you went to the toilet so you know
taking off your belt your watch you had
to be drug and alcohol tested there were
all these kind of you you were
constantly monitored by and surveilled
by by the management you were underpaid
so we weren't paid the minimum wage for
half the time I was working there one
girl I interviewed was paid 60 to P an
hour and it took her six weeks to get
that money back over Christmas there was
all this stuff going on and my as soon
as I got in there - its Eve reaction was
like why does no one know about this and
then it became then there became then it
was kind of a zeal attached to the
project to kind of tell the story of of
the stuff that was going on there and it
was a similar Amazon was the worst in
that respect but there was though it was
there were similar things that were true
when I worked in social care in
Blackpool when I was an uber driver in
London and when I was in a call centre
in in South Wales it was it was it was
revelatory to me more than you know
before I told the story to anyone else
it really like shocked me first of all
and I'm listening to this and I'm
thinking to myself how can they get away
with paying lower than the minimum wage
how can they possibly do that it's
surely not legal is it knows I mean it's
completely illegal I mean there's
several several reasons so on the one
hand it's the agency who pays your wages
so Amazon management would be the people
who we dealt with for things like you
know like if you take it out sick or
whatever or just just productivity
targets it'd be the Amazon management
but then you had an agency an employment
agency would deal with the payroll
things and they would put down the
underpayment of wages to incompetency
she isn't an excuse I mean you still
breaking the law but most of the people
we were working with I was working with
were migrants migrant workers so some of
them couldn't speak very good English so
how
they expected to phone up payroll or
whatever and the agency themselves would
just fob you off and say oh you know
you'll receive the rest of your money
next week or whatever and just didn't
expect to encounter people like
undercover journalists and people like
me in there who would then tell the
story of what was going on but it's it
in fact like there's a law there with
the minimum wage but for some people in
our society it exists mainly on paper
does that make sense if you don't know
that what the law is because you've come
from Romania and you don't even speak
the local language very well right
you're not gonna know what the law is
you're not gonna have the ability to
have it enforced in your behalf and the
other thing about the precariousness of
what you talk about in the book is these
people are under constant threat of
losing their job for going to the toilet
you know what would happen if they
actually start demanding their workers
right yeah I mean there's there's that
yeah that the fact that that you're
dealing with the management is dealing
with migrant workers makes it their hand
is weet feels weaker in a sense because
on the one hand they don't necessarily
understand the what the law of the land
is in Britain in terms of employment
rights when you get a pay slip it
doesn't say what the minimum wage is it
doesn't print the minimum wage on the
pay slip which is one thing I've been
saying that that would be a really easy
change the government could make - so
make sure what everyone knows what the
minimum wage actually is and the
employment agency the the
representatives of that agency were
really elusive as well so it'd be hard
to find them often hard to get hold of
them and yeah and they would just rudely
like fob you off if you if you ever
inquired about your pay I mean the girl
the young woman who was it who was
paying it paid so grossly underpaid 62 P
an hour she told me it took six weeks to
get the money back from the employment
agency and that was only because her mum
was phoning up all the time threatening
to like go to a Cass and yeah and she
said she would have been screwed and
homeless if she hadn't lived with her
mum and yeah it just felt like um they
just didn't care and they were
complacent in that in the sense that
they wouldn't assume someone like me was
in the warehouse for a start and they
know that those none of those people
have any kind of voice in in the media
or whatever they're not going to be you
know I see some some kind of migrant
worker from a warehouse in the West
in this small town of Rugeley which no
one's ever heard of writing a column in
in the newspaper damming their their
treatment at work you just don't really
see that so I guess that's partly why it
was allowed to go on and was everybody
in the warehouse on zero hours contracts
not everyone in the warehouse all the
people I worked we all were so all the
people who did the job I did work so you
know if you're in a managerial role
you're not on a zero hours contract but
all of us we worked for to it over to to
employment agencies there was trans line
and PMP and all of us were on zeroes
contracts I'm so Amazon Amazon says you
know we don't employ people on zero
hours contracts but no because they
employ them through an agent the agency
employees and one zero hours contracts
so this means here you'd work we worked
like four or four days a week ten and a
half hours each day and then something
you know I remember one Thursday we were
told the warehouse was going to be
closed on the Saturday just for meit for
maintenance whatever that was and
because we weren't your honor zero hours
contract that can happen so you were
down your wages are down kind of you
know you lose ten and a half hours that
we so so yeah we were all on we were all
on zero contracts and for American
listeners and viewers man it's not just
American we've got Malaysian followers
but so for our international viewers and
listeners what is a zero hours contract
and why do you do you think they are
such a toxic thing to our employment yes
zero hours contracts is basically you
have no guaranteed hours each week but
typically you can't get on the job as
well so that so with the the company
you're employed by this company so you
can't claim like Social Security you
can't get another job but you don't know
what you're working necessarily from
week to week in terms of hours so one
week you might have five would be
working five hours the next week you
might be working thirty-five hours and
it's you know it's not always bad
because I mean I I had a zero hours
contract when I was a student I was a
postman as well
and during like term time I would just
work five hours on a Saturday that
during my holidays I would work kind of
full-time but the problem is many of the
zeros contracts are used to basically
troll control the workforce so you have
a sense where you have a situation where
sometimes people is just getting one or
two hours a week and then they can't get
another job at the same time they're
constantly uncool and they also can't
sign on for Social Security so you
you're not making much money you can't
get another job you're kind of in limbo
really and if you leave your job if you
quit the job you can't then sign on for
Social Security because you've left
voluntarily whereas you know to get to
get Jobseeker's Allowance say to get to
get Social Security you need to have
lost your job kind of involuntarily you
can't just quit and then go go sign on
anymore anymore so you get have lots of
people stuck in this kind of limbo where
they're not getting enough hours it's
not making enough money and then often
the state has to then subsidize that's
really like tax credits etc anyway and
yet you have and you also have this this
insecurity hanging over their heads
where they're not they're not getting
enough you know they don't know where
the money's coming from week to week on
the pro side Amazon a very good at
painted to dig into that a little bit
later but tell us more about you're
working in this warehouse you've got a
device like a bit of like a mobile phone
right or something like that a handheld
device that's tracking you every
movement it's keeping an eye on how long
you're spending working it's keeping an
eye on how long you spend going to the
toilet it's keeping an eye on all this
stuff and it's all used to measure your
productivity essentially right so you're
treated very much like a robot like a
cog in a machine what other kind of
things just just for people at home
because when you talk about you know you
almost kind of gum
we almost glanced over this idea that
you're working in this place and if you
get ill and you have a doctor who says
James is ill and you call in and say I'm
ill you are still being disciplined for
that right yeah so I mean that's crazy I
mean that is crazy right so what other
kind of stuff that was happening in
these places that people don't know
about yeah I mean the the sickness
policy was one of the most shocking
things so I took it that I was actually
I was actually ill one day that had a
very heavy cold tried to work through it
then I wanted to test out that what
policy actually was so the following day
I phoned in in the morning you know they
said you had to phone and I think it's
three hours before I did that and also
said you know I can go to the NHS
walk-in Center get a note from the
doctors if you need that as well and
they said on the phone you know you know
that's fine you don't need that you
phoned us you'd let us know then when I
went in the next day this this Amazon
rep came around with the clipboard
looking for me and you know said can you
confirm you were you off sick yesterday
and then he said you know I've been
given a point for this so what's that a
disciplinary point if you get sick you
lose your job and I queried it and said
this doesn't seem fair because I you
know I was genuine available when I was
when I was there you could see this and
said about the doctors no and he said
you know it doesn't matter his reasoning
was you know this is what Amazon have
always done as if you know it's like in
a school where the teachers like because
I said so it doesn't tell me anything
that was the justification and there
were also things like you know I noticed
every the beginning of every shift you'd
have this like you'd have almost like a
team meeting they give you like a
briefing before you they sent you out to
the to the warehouse and they would they
would keep talking about this thing
called idle time like you're clocking up
too much as they call it idle time and
it's like what what is this and then I
was a member always held one day you
know you have too much idle time when
you're on your device because it
measures where you are productivity etc
what you're doing and it dawned on me
you know eventually this is just the
time you know you have got 10 minutes
idle time say during a shift and that's
just a toilet break it's like because to
go on the toilet to the toilet we had
two toilets on the bottom floor of this
huge warehouse 700,000 square foot
warehouse two toilets on the bus like 10
football pitches
yeah they wasn't there was boast about
it being like 10 football pitches for
some reason yeah like a phallic like
boast and like the the two toilets are
on the bottom floor and you have to go
down four flights of stairs because
there's four floors I was on the top
floor and you have to go through
security to go to the bathroom which
takes the airport style security so you
know it takes takes time to go through
and there
you know it's so going the bathroom
takes ten minutes typically about ten
minutes and you're being given people
are being given disciplinaries for idle
time and it's just taking bathroom
breaks during a ten and a half hour
shift
you need to take bathroom breaks right
if you don't drink enough water you get
a headache because you're doing your
walking ten miles a day yeah I mean that
that was shocking I mean you have you
had half an hour break and then two
ten-minute breaks and by the time you
get to the canteen on these breaks
you're getting like 15-minute break for
the for the half an hour break and then
you get an extra five minutes for the
added on to the ten-minute breaks but
you have about seven minutes break when
you get to the can sitting through
security and stuff so you're hardly
getting any break time the productivity
targets were insane I was I'm someone
who goes to the gym who's relatively fit
and healthy and I was told the first
week that I was in the bottom 10% of
productivity and I was running around
this warehouse
you get disciplinary for running even
though you have to run to meet your
productivity targets and this whole
state of affairs is is kind of its kind
of plastered over with this this
verbiage this nonsense so by you know
you're not allowed to call the warehouse
to warehouse you have to call it
fulfillment center it's like yeah I mean
it's like a cult and if you I was
already in the labor place if you um if
you if you lose your job you're not
fired or sacked you're released well it
sounds like you are released from quite
a situation actually yeah we used to
joke whereas we used to joke you've been
promoted to a customer yeah if you get
called an associate right yeah and it's
um you're not workers but there's no
work as bosses or management you're all
associates Joe you're on the same level
as Jeff is yeah we were told you know
like word for word
Jeff Beezus is an associate and so are
you we're all one big happy family here
at Amazon on the first day directing
Jeff business makes sixty two P an hour
well yeah he does well that's what he
declares anyway well this one question I
wanted to ask why airport security just
to go to the toilet so they can see
yes it's concerned about theft is its
purported I know exactly I mean it's
supposedly you know if you treat people
that poorly they're gonna next stuff and
I can see the rationale for that you pay
sixty to be an hour you probably got a
Nick stuff to survive so I'm there I
know you can some people is a human
nature whatever it is some people don't
they think they're paranoid all the time
that you're going to next stuff so they
have this security you've got to go
through every time you go to the
bathroom you all go and break or leave
and what was the atmosphere like in the
warehouse their morale sorry for was
were they fulfilled we love the time you
weren't like I mean there was also a
prohibition on talking to your people
you're working with so you had to do
that surreptitiously the morale I mean
it was the atmosphere was like some kind
of low-rent part of prison or something
it was um
people just used to people would not be
there very long most people so you it
was easy to get fired so if you've got
six points you'd lose your job and
you're getting points for I mean some
people have got points because the bus
was late the Amazon bus bringing them in
was late so they clocked in late and
then they all got given points for this
blocking in that 15 minutes late your
office it you get a point point for too
many toilet breaks point for low
productivity and you're on four or five
or six points you've got you're gone all
the jobs are temporary nine-month
contracts anyway so you see you're not
seeing people you see some people like
you make a friend and then a few days
later they just vanished
and it's they've been fired or they've
just quit because it's they can't stand
it anymore so people just walking around
with these trolleys like drones almost
just super tired your feet kind of
extremely sore because the distances you
have to walk you're not provided special
Footwear and it was um I mean that yeah
I worked any yogurt factory once and I
worked in a toilet paper factory once
and it's like morale in those places
isn't like it's not like a part it's not
like some party every day but this was
this was something else this was um yeah
it's just people who know they're being
exploited mostly Romanian migrants who
would
on various occasions would compare it to
me to modern slavery I wouldn't use
those Serbs because I thought out that
some it's wrong they would say no this
is like we feel like slaves to be fellow
slaves it was just um yeah it was just
completely like eye-opening I've never
really seen anything like that in the UK
anyway and what responsibility do you
think customers have who buy from Amazon
and you know and they go well it's cheap
I get the book that I want it's
convenient do we have responsibility
yeah I mean I mean of course I mean it's
there are there like a million there's
like infinite ways to kind of
rationalize why it's fine
well you know I need this Amazon Prime
thing or I need this book like instantly
and I've done it before like I had
Amazon for my 2003 or sometime around
then and it's I'd be getting these like
these quick super quick deliveries not
as quick as my I would never kind of
never really think about what was going
on dyma supply chain in the same way
that you know 100 years ago you Britain
had a had an empire and you have all
this stuff being bought and sold in in
kind of the colonies and and benefitting
basically British consumers and just
don't ask any questions and is fine but
then when you start to delve into it
like as I did and as other people have
you you kind of realize that this has
consequences this kind of the speed the
kind of the cheapness
there's a cost to it and the cost is
borne by people in these warehouses
people along the supply chain who
conveniently we don't hear from most of
the time um that was one of the reasons
I did the book so we key it's just kind
of give those people some kind of voice
and actually find that kind of just kind
of shove it down the throats of people
who you know consumers who who don't
maybe don't think about this stuff in
the nicest possible way and in the book
you don't just talk about Amazon so tell
us about some of the other jobs that you
took on for this for this research yeah
so I did I was social carer
so like domiciliary care so that's like
visiting hyster house in the town of
Blackpool yeah so driving around in my
car
you're kind of on a zero hours contract
again it's 20 minute care visits for
elderly and disabled people typically so
you'd work to be working from about 7:00
in the morning to 2:00 with the two hour
break and then two then four till tenant
tenant evening roughly a typical day and
here is looking after people who
probably just hold on
so you started work at 7:00 in the
morning and you finish work at 10:00 in
the evening yeah you have a break in the
middle but yeah oftentimes you don't
take the break because you can't get
everything done if you take the full
full break because you have everything
you have 20 minute care visits right you
go to Blackpool has a high rate of like
health problems ms particularly so you
have lots of um disabled and elderly
people lots of people move there to
retire so they went to Blackpool when
for their summer holidays and they think
you know this is a lovely place to
retire so you have a hi oh hi elderly
population as well so you have lots of
people also low incomes where their care
is subsidized by the local authority
your your visiting them your you'll your
going say 7:00 in the morning your your
getting them out of bed if your taking
this to the bathroom to use the toilet
washing them making them tea preparing
their breakfast dressing them either
taking them back to bed if they're very
you know if it's palliative care say all
you'll to attain to the living room and
putting the TV there favorite TV
programs on whatever it is and giving
them medication filling out the
paperwork all of this within like 20
minutes which is uh in practice almost
never possible never achievable it's
very hard to do that within 20 minutes
so then you can then say you do do it
within 20 minutes you have ten minutes
then to drive to your next appointment
you're not paid for the ten minutes so
you're only paid for the 20 minute
blocks of care visits so you're
basically paid but I don't wage again
because driving from house the house is
it's work time right you're in your work
uniform you're not doing other things
you're you're going from workplace or
workplace but you're not paid for that
so that answers the question I guess
about you know are you working all this
time no because you get any of these
10-minute breaks all the time and you're
working through your proper breaks
because you can't do all of that stuff
within
cavitus and that was the most so one
care worker told me you know their treat
they feel like they're treated like
glorified cleaners no disrespect to
cleaners but the level of responsibility
you have as a carer it's a different
kind of job and you're basically looking
after people who fought in the Second
World War fought in the Korean War and
you're treating them like dirt because
the care system is screwed basically so
that's what I did in Blackpool then I
went to South Wales where I worked in a
call centre for Admiral that was the
least bad job I mean Admiral made an
effort actually to make you feel okay
like my book is I think my book is has
more kind of credibility in that when
when a company does treat you well and
does do things to make it a bit better
the workplace I'm completely honest
about I don't necessarily try and you
know paint them is like these these
employers as these demons like Admiral
treat us fairly well the job was was
poorly paid still it was very
commissioned dependent so if he didn't
make you commissioned you wouldn't have
much money that week but they made an
effort to actually try and make the
workplace you know a more a more
pleasant place though which was in
contrast to say Amazon then from South
Wales I went I came back to London and I
worked as an uber driver for two and a
half months I think it's two and a half
months yeah and that was a again it was
easier and won some respects in that you
you know if I don't want to work one day
I just don't turn my phone on which is
you know I don't have some boss like on
my case all the time but it was also it
was very not very much like
self-employment
despite the kind of because that's the
argument realisme it's flexibility gives
you the opportunity you're a boss right
so it's not like that no so I mean there
was again uber that was it was coming
back into a world where there was all
this language which kind of blurred the
distinction between the reality and
there was like the rhetorical universe
and the flesh-and-blood universe and the
two were very very different so you know
be your own boss we kept hearing from
uber on our induction day autonomy
flexibility if the wheels aren't turning
you aren't earning all of this crap
yeah like vomit-inducing trash and then
um but also and you know you'd sacrifice
for this autonomy you'd suck you'd you
didn't receive a minimum wage you didn't
receive holiday pay sick or and sick pay
or annual leave and autonomy actually
didn't really exist beyond turning your
phone on and off beyond long logging in
and out of the app so we were told
during our induction you have this
induction day uber before you go out
when they show you teach you how to use
the applet cetera and we were told by
this kind of hip guy in like you know
jeans and t-shirt you know trying to you
know that's the sort of person I see
around Shoreditch or oxidant hipster
knew they were [ __ ] evil kombucha
drinking hipster that you know that we
weren't allowed to pick and you choose
which jobs we did so whatever whatever
job you were sends you you have to
accept it so that was the words that use
you can't pick and choose what jobs you
do which which that doesn't sound like
self-employment you know if you're
actually self-employed
that's what you do it like I'm a
self-employed journalist if I didn't
want to do such a job I can say that
that's not worth my while to do it based
on the money or whatever we were even
told what we were allowed to talk about
with the passengers in the back of our
car so you're not allowed to talk about
politics religion or sport which that is
like all cab drivers do yeah and if your
rating fell below four point seven stars
you know the customer leaves you are
rating one to five stars every time they
have a ride if it fell below four point
seven stars you would be you could be
you ran the rest of being deactivated
all of the [ __ ] it just sounds like is
from some kind of novel yeah yeah and
yet here we are we are here in London
other people watching this may be using
the uber buying stuff on Amazon we're
all buying these Primark t-shirts that
are made by slave laborers wherever they
are right
we've all got phones that are made with
made by Chinese people who who are
jumping out of factories to just because
they hate it so much with precious
metals mined by slaves in Africa
whatever and
on the one hand it's terrible on the
other hand I don't see like literally as
I'm just being honest as I see hit sit
here right now I'm listening to all this
and I'm going this is horrible what can
I do about it
[ __ ] all leave uber driver tip nice big
tip yeah that hit that I joke but that
is actually like one of the worst things
about when I was driving for uber is
once you take out all your expenses you
you basically unjust over the minimum
wage less than the London living wage so
it was eight pounds something an hour it
worked out one side subtracted like you
know car insurance for a private hire
drivers like 70 odd pounds a week three
three three grand a year just quite high
you know cost of washing the car
regularly like valeting it regularly so
I mean yeah one thing you can do is
leave uber drivers as heavy you know if
it's just a few pounds like every time
you use it because they're not making
enough money don't leave them leave them
five-star ratings
unless I know unless someone was like
really horrible as some real reason not
to leave them a five-star rating just as
standard things like this can and also
when there's a court case going on now
with um uber drivers a like in the final
state I think it goes to the high core
where the drivers have claimed they're
not really self employed based on the
things some other kinds of things I've
I've told told you today and ubers lost
to cool cases and it's going to the hike
or and whether the whether you be
drivers should be classed as
self-employed contractors or workers so
they're self-employed workers and then
employee
employees it's like a mid category so
they should be done be entitled to the
minimum wage and annual leave and so I'd
say you know follow the case and and
there are ways to support the kind of
the trade unions which are pursuing that
case yeah I mean like if you just look
into it there are you there are ways to
offer support to those drivers who are
saying that they're not actually
self-employed I guess my point more
broadly though is I feel like that is
something that requires a systemic
solution because take your book it's
it's on Amazon right and you've talked
about the fact that you had to put it on
Amazon because otherwise no one would
publish it yeah so the power of these
masses and I'm not saying that as a kind
of you're a hypocrite kind of thing as I
totally get it
because it's a trap we're all in
trap these corporations have so much
power now and they have such a hold of
the the running of our societies the
market for these goods the market for
these services the market for this labor
that we're all trapped you know and I
and I guess the question is is there
anything that even at the government
level we can do about it now
yeah I mean I thought you're gonna be
every every every book talk I do there's
always one person who says are you books
for sale on Amazon and it's like they
think no one's ever asked me that before
I'd like it see this brilliant like
gotcha I know I thought you're gonna do
that no I told you mind it's not what we
do here
I might we really just want to get to
the bottom of it and what I see and I
think what a lot of people see you know
Andrew yang isn't presidential candidate
America who's talked about you know
automation and the impact that's gonna
have is all of this [ __ ] is trapping us
into the system from which there is no
escape
and the problem is Francis said very
accurately they don't pay tax so even
the benefits of automation of all of
this stuff of them you know slave
driving Romanians to work harder and
harder and whistle we're still not
seeing the benefits of that society
that's just going into the pockets of
billionaires yeah I mean Amazon's
Amazon's only in Luxembourg because
geographically is in the center of
Europe is not because the tax that I'm
sure they do loads of sales and
Luxembourg huge market it's a great
country not to do that yeah I mean the
Amazon in terms of the book thing is the
so yeah I get this question all the time
and the first answer is that my
publisher wouldn't publish me if I said
I'm not gonna say I refuse to sell it on
Amazon they must find someone else to do
it because Amazon is the biggest book
distributor if any book which is which
boycotts Amma's and typically it's gonna
bomb it's not gonna because that's where
most people buy their books now and you
know the idea that it's hypocritical is
also kind of false time because it
offers don't benefit from this amazon
discounts heavily therefore authors are
getting a smaller cut from from those
books which discounts it which is sold
and second-hand books obviously so
so you get kind of I got screwed in the
warehouse that's screwed when I put my
book for sale on Amazon as well and it's
a case of you know with audio books
pretty much everyone gets their
audiobooks from audible now which is an
Amazon company so it's I mean a
publisher cannot put a book on all it
audible but then just no one's gonna see
it or buy it you have it's almost a
monopoly basically so you don't really
have a choice as a as a producer you
know of books and whatever not to not to
put it on on those those things and and
yeah you see that kind of that creep
into into other areas like they want to
get in some other companies want to get
into healthcare now they have all this
data on us there also there are also you
know with with Google etc and and ads
they're also selling us things based on
on data they have about us you know
selling those things almost you're
you're kind of buying things almost
subconsciously because you've been
bombarded with these ads that they've
went from this data they've accumulated
about essays like that isn't my area but
you can see where it's kind of going oh
we've had people on the show we had a
good friend of mine people Mangrum who's
a former presidential adviser has her
own tech company now talks about all
this stuff but the question for me is
what do we do about the power of these
corporations and the way that they're
treating people and the fact that as
consumers I mean you can tell people
don't use Amazon right but it's like
saying to people don't go outside you
know as a solution to a particular point
it's not gonna work because of the as I
said the power that they've now
accumulated right so is there is there
something that the government can do is
there something that you know do we need
some kind of legislation and place to
deal with these things is there a
solution that you think that might work
yeah I mean I I don't think you like
consumer boycotts at the be-all end-all
of taking on these companies which treat
people like this
like I mean personally I think one of
the things that that's missing in say
the Amazon ways is there's no trade
union in there I mean if you had if you
have this is part of a broader question
of kind of the the kind of depth of kind
of grassroots like aisles of like
working-class democracy whether whether
that
kind of social clubs whether that's
trade unions whether even like religious
organizations the kind of like and this
isn't necessarily left-wing argument so
everyone but you know the little
platoons where you have these kind of
small kind of organizations where where
you can kind of have that democratic
kind of forum like at the grassroots
level and you need that in you need to
make it easier for trade unions to get
into places like Amazon because at the
moment if you go giving out trade union
forms in the car even in the car this
huge carpark lamps and you're chased off
by security film the police are called
just to give out forms to tell workers
what their rights are and if you if you
get if you have workers organizing
themselves in these places government
has to do less as well so you don't need
the government kind of constantly having
to send people from HMRC to these
companies because it becomes self an
organic self self-regulating thing if
you if you have a union which willing to
talk with management but willing to also
strike when when some of these things
you know ridiculous things are going on
in the in these workplaces but you have
to you I mean empowering people in
themselves the very people who are
working in this place is um is is I
think what we need to do because if you
just legislate from top-down if you just
pass these laws sometimes they only
exist on paper because as we talked
about already the people in those places
I they don't know the law have no means
to actually enforce them whereas if you
get workers banding together and
organizing themselves you can actually
you can actually take a stand against
some of this stuff but that's kind of
the trade union movement has been partly
to fight the union's themselves partly
the fault of legislation and the
changing nature of work the union
movements been been declining for the
last kind of thirty thirty almost forty
years I guess now in terms when you were
telling me this again and you're
explaining it it's it's really
terrifying it's very very scary do you
think that we're moving towards that
sort of future where the majority of
jobs are going to be like that and it's
only going to be a select for you there
are actually protecting you've got
workers rights as we compete more and
more with you know with China and all
the other countries I mean it's
certainly possible with
the kind of there was a very good book I
read recently called the glow buttocks
revolution and it was about kind of how
we really failed the last period of
disruption like Dean -
deindustrialization say the the 80s and
90s I mean I visited some of those
places in the book say South Wales we
really failed - it left such an
appalling legacy in many parts of the
country so in in Blaenau Gwent in in
south wales you still have one in six
people on antidepressants which is a
legacy of kind of worklessness since the
pits and and the power stations and
steel works were all closed not all but
but mostly closed very very rapidly and
people didn't get get new jobs and kind
of just stagnated and got ill and etc
and his argument in this book argues
that you know if we fail this time with
the next big wave of disruptions coming
in terms of jobs being outsourced to say
you know you can get translation you can
get a Chinese graduate to translate a
piece of piece of work now for you over
the internet a fraction of the price of
what people are doing it for in Britain
so these jobs are going you have
automation robots doing people's
people's jobs and if we don't if we deal
with this disruption as poorly as we
dealt with the last wave of disruption
you will have this situation where it's
not just there are a kind of waves of
middle-class people thrown out of work
as well so you have you will have this
big kind of section of the population
which is dissing like doing just just
unskilled work such as such as I've done
in the book which is poorly remunerated
you you lack kind of security you can't
get a house or something or a mortgage
on on this stuff and that's that those
people are typically very angry and then
there's a political backlash from that
as we've seen he argues this book argues
that brexit is the partly the kind of
the delayed kind of backlash to the last
wave of the last disruption so you have
these people in places like Sunderland
places like South Wales where the
industrialization you know over a period
of years has left these kind of angry
middle-aged men basically who've not
been able to work who feel like
societies left them behind and they've
kind of kicked back against the system
with brexit in the states with with the
election
Trump places in in say France or eastern
Germany by voting for marine lepen or
the the AFD in Germany and and it can
only get worse if more and more people
are put through that kind of disruption
if it's if it's the more the biggest
section of societies put through that
disruption the worse the political
backlash will be and you'll see you'll
see you could again see something like
in the 1930s I know this is always
bandied around and like you know several
years ago you know people comparing
Trump to Hitler and all this ridiculous
like nonsense but if the if there's that
much economic disruption it usually it's
usually followed by nasty political
extremism weather usually the far-right
and then followed by kind of Stalinism
and or this or this this crap as well
well this is a thing is like we talked
about dreaming a bit earlier this is one
of the things that he talks about is
that if you look at the election of
Donald Trump the states that he won that
he really needed to win the weather
states where 4 million jobs I think he's
talking about what automated away and
it's only gonna get much much worse now
shopping malls are gonna close trucking
jobs are gonna go as you say
middle-class like translation League a
lot of legal documents just get drafted
automatically now will be in the next
ten years so it's gonna get worse and
this is this is why it has to be talked
about it has to be addressed and it's
not just the right like you know you
talk about from the left but two people
on the right I would say is well look
look at the Romanians are working in the
Amazon warehouse right they are the
reason that two part to some extent
people are concerned about the levels of
immigration because we had a lot of
immigration and you know if we weren't
creating these conditions in which most
British people wouldn't even want to
work right you wouldn't have these
people coming over here in the first
place so it's not a left versus right
issued this is an issues that can affect
everybody isn't it I mean it's a huge
issue can I just interrupt what should
they job constant and trigonometry but
you also used to be a translator yeah
used to be a translator so gives money
to give money to Constantine but
actually I mean before I stop
pretty much it was automations happening
man yeah yeah you put something into
Google Translate it proved it does as
good a job as like 90% of translators
really yeah for something folk for basic
things if you just want to understand
the meaning of a text yeah it's enough
well no just and and it's only gonna
continue so lots of people are gonna
lose the job but let's talk about the
political side of this when you wrote
the book it came out last year right
2018 yeah what was the the response to
that first of all from the companies
involved and also from the wider public
politicians etc I mean the response from
the companies it varied from you know
extremely hostile to no response so
Amazon just yeah was it extremely
hostile anytime I was on it on the TV or
on the radio they would you know put out
a statement first of all it was just
spewing kind of specific things you know
like James only works at Amazon like
nine days I mean but it's like this is
spread over the the month so it's like
in shift so it kind of doesn't make any
difference it doesn't really mean
anything then things like you know we we
don't have any we don't employ people on
zero hours contracts at Amazon yeah you
get an agency to employ people on zero
hours contracts then it became about you
know James only wrote this book to get
publicity it's like it's not you can't
there's nothing you can prove or
disprove it's just you know James only
wrote this sensationalizes stuff to sell
books and like what can you say to that
and my job is to sell books but that
doesn't mean I'm making things up as I
said when companies didn't behave like
that I was very honest about that and
you as a journalist like your job is
bound up with your the integrity of what
you write so the idea that I'm gonna go
and make stuff up and like put my whole
reputation on the line to to say that
people that Amazon were afraid to go to
the toilet just make that up is nonsense
and it's all backed up by surveys that
have been done of the workers in these
warehouses so group could organize did a
survey of workers in the roost
rudely Amazon warehouse I worked in find
seventy four percent of people who work
they were afraid to go to the toilet
because of productivity targets so then
when I find a bottle of urine in the
warehouse coke bottle filled with urine
the warehouse because someone's been
afraid to go to the toilet it may make
sense it's not like I'm just making
something up is that you can see the
situation where why this is going on so
Amazon yeah I've been it's been very
hostile they've they've not owned as it
were they're they're kind of their
mistakes in my view they they increase
the minimum wage for their workers in
British and American warehouses last
year but it was only after like a slew
of negative publicity from my book from
the GMB trade union Bernie Sanders did
this big campaign against Amazon then
suddenly they realized that maybe
they're not paying people I lost money
and be Jeff Bezos you know portrays it
is this great act of philanthropy on his
bar when he's basically just been shamed
into into doing it uber didn't haven't
responded at all presumably because
they'd say that they're not let it
employ anyone admiral haven't responded
presumably because I was I was I was
fairly generous towards them so it's
it's kind of speaks for itself and the
care company you know of they didn't
respond specifically to they just said
something like you know we we do our
best in a difficult environment we don't
necessarily we don't necessarily agree
with agree with the representation of
the sector that James is portrayed in
the book but it wasn't it wasn't kind of
that hostile and that was like one time
they said this was Amazon has been a
most awesome was has there been any
politicians who took this as something
to to work on to run on to talk about
yeah I mean I've been I've always
forgotten axis most of that was last
year I mean I've been um I did some
videos with Bernie Sanders in the States
which is pretty cool we did some we're
losing we're losing viewers -
yes none of us is a big fan of socialism
but this is like I say this is this is
not a partisan issue this is an issues
can affect everybody yes I mean we did I
did some videos of Bernie Sanders but
then also I've got some endorsements on
my book from you know conservatives I
can't remember who now but there are you
know there's conservatives endorsed my
book I went to I've been to speak it
like conservative think-tanks I also
speak to pension investment funds
businesses about this stuff so it's not
again it's not just it's not just being
on the left that makes you want to see
people treated with dignity and respect
and have some security in their lives I
think I'll say the book isn't a polemic
it isn't like I think isn't a sermon it
isn't it kind of isn't something you
read in the newspaper where the
Communist Party of Britain Marxist
Leninist it's it's it's kind of more
immoral argument just because you don't
go to university just because you don't
leave you at the time you live it you're
born and brought up in just because
you're not saying necessarily academic
doesn't mean you're any less of a human
being doesn't mean you're you're you
deserve to be treated in this way the
people who are treated often in the book
it's a it's very straightforward a very
simple argument that I think anyone
wherever they stand politically can well
last year you you you you believe in the
works of Ayn Rand okay I guess it's you
can you can buy into that I think she's
a great writer guys we wanted to tell
you we're very excited to say we've got
a new sponsor which is hellofresh
indeed we have hellofresh is a UK's
leading recipe box service delivering
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
step-by-step recipes to your door it is
the easy convenient way to cook
delicious dinners from scratch every
single time choose your favorites from
19 recipes every week they have a whole
range of options there for you including
recipes that are ready in under 20
minutes there's family favorites there's
British cuisine there's world cuisine
hellofresh we're offering trigonometry
fans
60 pounds of four boxes to take
advantage of that go to hello fresh
dakota UK enter our special code which
is a
course trigonometry and enjoy delicious
dinners without any of the drama the
fresh ingredients come direct from
suppliers ie they've been picked by
Constantine's family you can tell
Francis studied geography at a British
school because he can't tell the
difference between Russia and Romania
doesn't matter mate
same thing breaks it means breaks it and
the great thing is it's been
proportioned for you so there's no food
waste
just like in my home country of
Venezuela the great thing we've had
fresh is that you're gonna be able to
choose from 19 different recipes every
week so there is something for everybody
you're gonna be able to eat with you
kids it's going to be no fuss dinnertime
it's going to be solved yeah I really
like the rapid box which allows you to
cook things in under under 20 minutes
but the great thing about hellofresh as
well is it actually allows you to open
up your cooking range so most households
on average have about 6 recipes that
they cook regularly hellofresh has up to
19 so you can kind of expand a little
bit in terms of your cooking and of
course they also don't have a fixed
subscription so there's no term you can
cancel you can skip weeks you can change
the size of the box you can change the
livery address you can do all kinds of
stuff to suit your life to enjoy
delicious moment head over to hello
fresh coat UK choose your box choose
your delivery slot and add your favorite
recipes discover the easy way to get
delicious dinners from scratch and if
you do that you'll get sick abs just
like me hello fresh we're offering
trigonometry fans 60 pounds off four
boxes to take advantage of that go to
hello fresh taco de UK enter our special
code which is of course trigonometry and
enjoy delicious dinners without any of
the drama
[Music]
so we've been talking we've touched on
the left now so you're very much of the
left however you have had your your
issues shall we say with some members
with people on the left where do you see
the lift at the moment and the way it's
progressing yeah I mean yeah I kind of
fallen out with a lot of the left to
kind of persona non-grata basically our
face tattoos at this point in terms of
say I wanted to be pursue a career on in
politics or something yeah that's that's
not happening um but what why is that
because how long you've just been
talking about something that is you know
the left should be absolutely well
everybody but in particularly left
should be absolutely outraged by and if
it's their narrative of these global
corporations who don't care about the
individual exploiting them and you come
in and you expose them on your hero I'm
a bit of a troll online to be first
I always put on my strap line on Twitter
the other day like more left-wing in
person but but I don't know I mean
there's there I do have genuine beef I
do have a genuine beef with with a lot
of the left over things like a lot of it
rolls around kind of foreign policy
stuff so so when you know years ago I
lived in Cuba for six months like ten
years just over ten years ago you know I
saw what kinds of things going on no I
still friends arrested for you know
speaking out against the government
fired from the University of Havana for
for writing some mildly critical article
about the government people not allowed
to leave the country without permission
from the state not allowed to move to
different parts of the country without
permission from the state you see what's
going on in in Venezuela and I and these
like a few years ago you have all these
kind of people kind of like fanboys of
Venezuela saying about it like Jeremy
Corbyn Owen Jones is then you know this
is a new model of socialism we need to
pursue meanwhile oh god kill me now I
remember I used to work for this blog
left foot forward used to edit it and I
remember once Boris Johnson was making
this an act that he wanted to bring
water cannons to London and we were we
were kind of
the stuff you know this is a bad idea
and I better enjoy his writing this
stuff for the newspaper or tweeting you
know this is a disgrace Brice Johnson
once the water cannon people in London I
mean what and he'd just written an
article about how great Venezuela was a
meanwhile they were actually water
counting people in Venezuela parody
doesn't count because they're all it's
kind of Syria you know Seamus Milne
Andrew Murray all these people just
assadís support you know a million
people being killed in Syria and they're
there they kind of you know umming and
ahhing about whether Assad is like use
chemical weapons and all this stuff
right that's that stuff is really
sickening okay but this is normal right
I mean in terms of the left should be a
place just like the right and unlike the
center where people have different
positions about foreign policy yeah
they have different positions about the
troops they have different views about
different kinds of things right and used
to be like any party any political
movement it's a broad Church it's a
coalition on the right you might have a
Ken Clark conservative and you might
have a Jacob Riis more conservative and
then the same party even though their
views on brexit even though their views
on many many things would be completely
different what seems to me to be
happening on the left those as we kind
of touched on is there is this sense
that there is one way and anyone who
departs from that is automatically a
heretic and they have to be exorcised
from from the movement is that accurate
do you feel yeah I mean so academic
David Hirsh calls it the community of
the good and if you you think if you
you're a heretic on one of these issues
if you're thinking isn't aligned for the
orthodoxy you have cast out of the
community of the good unless you're
Jeremy Corbyn and you secretly support
brexit but yeah you're allowed to stay
for summer isn't a lifelong anti-racist
but yeah it's very much like that I
think because being on the Left isn't
first of all it's a hangover from
Stalinism which style ism is a movement
was it was very much like a
like a teleological movement where where
you know if you're if you're wrong about
like che guevara said once that you know
he wanted to nuke he wanted to fire a
nuclear weapon at Miami because you're
saving the lives of future unborn
children or something that's that's the
core idea I think you said it but it's
anyway that's that's my mentality that
you have to be ideologically like
perfect because it's a life-and-death
struggle it's um good on a t-shirt
though James yeah if you're um you know
if you're wrong about something it has
these life-and-death consequences so you
know if you support austerity you're
responsible for the deaths of like
10,000 negative people or whether I see
people posting this stuff on Twitter all
the time you can't have a you can't have
a debate like that on those grounds
because then you have to know if
someone's really responsible for the
deaths of 10,000 people whoever ordered
s the death deaths a future unborn
children you you obviously have to know
platform them you could like if that's
true you know you murderous you can't
have those people within civilized
debate if once you start thinking like
that the same with no platform in you
know no platforming feminists no some
some kind of radical feminists are being
no platforms on the left because the
people who are doing that see this is
you know you're denying someone's right
to exist when you frame things in those
terms as this kind of this this kind of
struggle of black and white struggle
this binary struggle of good versus evil
then it becomes very easy to just them
completely like deep platform completely
kind of like exclude people from from
the community of their good or in states
where that's the ruling ideology to put
them in prison and kill them I mean
that's what happened in the in the in
the Soviet Union and again you don't
need to compare you know exaggerate and
compare our current situation to that
but it's there's a way of thinking which
in search kind of simple moral
moralistic kind of teleological terms
where history has his endpoint and and
you've got to do it doesn't you what's a
mere human being who's excluded from the
debate if we're heading towards this
glorious socialist future that way of
thinking has permeated kind of
thinking on the left I think in sections
of the left at any rate and why do you
think that it's come back because the
way you're talking it's my mother's from
Venezuela and that's it and that's the
sign for everybody who listen to the
podcasts or watch it to have a drink but
but but why why is it come back because
you think shortly is 2019 we have we
should have seen that this these systems
don't work they just simply don't
function yeah I mean I guess it's
politics I mean there's there's we
talked about reasons why politics is
kind of chaotic right now I mean you
have this sections of the population
heavily disenfranchised I think though
on the other hand I think that and
there's there's also I mean other
authors Jamie Bartlett for example who
writes a lot about tech tech stuff he he
can talk about things like Pope wife
society's become more polarized online
and and what and the online arena
whatever but I think it's politics has
taken on a kind of religious Hugh if you
like again so it's it's become much more
of a like surrogate religion or as Annie
chocolate you know it's a generated
Christianity so it's you speak to people
who like really enthused by Jeremy
Corbyn and what they'll say is they'll
say oh you know Corbin's given me a
reason to get up in the morning but that
said it's you they'll say this you you
know since Corbin is like you hear this
all the time if you if you go to I can't
go to these things anymore if you go to
them you can see what is Christ momentum
thinking whatever when you speak to
especially some of the older people it's
a it's like a religious mania it's like
he's given them something to get up in
the morning and for many people this is
you know they get that from from
religion but many people on the Left get
that from the socialist movement so
Oscar Wilde said I think that you know
he said that the problem with socialism
is it takes up too many evenings well
for some people this is why they like it
it's because it gives their life a
meaning they don't have things to do in
the evenings they get to go to a meeting
they get to feel like they're they're
changing the world and imbue them with a
certain morality as well a sense of we
are the right we are on the right side
of history we are doing something good
we care about other people yeah and so
like a person
kind of a absurdist I think life has no
meaning I think he's you know a big fun
big kind of follower of Albert Camus I
think life essentially has no meaning
beyond which the meaning which you
create for it and that may not have any
intrinsic value in itself but some
people can't accept that you know some
people need that kind of that feeling
that a life has some purpose to it and I
think most people probably do but I
think because the world's become more
chaotic seemingly in the last say decade
since the since the recession with this
disruption in work and things like you
know the the rise of disruptive behavior
from from Russia the war in Syria all of
this stuff when the world's chaos that
you see a gravitation again towards
these certainties of whether it's
religion or whether it's um
a surrogate religion such as say
communism well if you it's interesting
talking about socialism wiped what you
were asking why this ideology is
resurgent to some extent I was trolled
by some American socialist on Twitter a
few weeks ago by Thomas it comes out
because Carlos Massa the guy who got
steven crowder band off YouTube he
tweeted out saying be gay be socialist
no platform bigots and I retweeted it
and I said I grew up in a socialist
country in the Soviet Union and you
would have been put in prison there for
being gay so how about you just noticed
that you live in the freest society in
history of the world and be grateful for
that
and a bunch of his followers came and
it's all like teenagers really yeah it's
all teenagers it's all very very young
people and I think partly that is
because there are some genuine problems
that you and I have covered on the show
along which is come if you're young
person you can't buy house yep you're
not gonna earn property as you talk
about your career you're not gonna have
a career necessarily you're gonna have
jobs but you might you're not gonna have
a career you don't know what you're
going to be doing ten or fifteen years
from now in terms of work you don't know
whether you're going to have a job you
don't know whether you can have income
so it's an economically and financially
very unstable time as well and I think
that's one of the reasons that it's some
things make a comeback because it's hard
to say to those kids well
tourism is great because it's not great
for them you know so I do think that
these issues which is why I'm so glad
you've come and showed these issues need
to be talked about in a rounded way you
can't look we've had Toby Young on the
show a couple of times and I like Toby
and I think he has some good ideas but
you know when he's just talking about
capitalism as a thing that's gonna save
everything well no it's not there are
going to be people who lose out
massively yeah and these these things
need to be addressed but one of the
things I wanted to ask you about is one
of the things that's happened on the
left it seems to me is that I guess I
feel like a lot more of them would care
about those people that you've written
about if their skin color was the right
color and if they were trans or if they
were you know LGBT or whatever and I get
the sense that we've become hyper
racialized and hypersensitive to all of
these things and that's driving a lot of
the narrative on the left is that fair
to say well I think it's it's basically
the decline of the politics of class in
a way in I think it's people think even
people who ostensibly of the left are
basically liberals in their thinking
about class so they think that's kind of
bin even though they may again they may
kind of pose as leftist or whatever
they're not really bothered about
exploitation in in that sense in the
sense of class so it's it's they they
almost they behave as if that's been
kind of that riddle has been solved the
riddle of kind of of class conflicts has
been solved and that you know they
behave as if society would be fine if in
the Amazon boardroom you had you know
50% men and 50% women and here 12%
ethnic minorities nevermind what went on
further down the chain as long as this
is you know represents as long as it is
representative then we've kind of solved
object and one trans here one trans
board member you've kind of solved this
solved this problem and you this kind of
attitude kind of permeates a lot of what
passes for life and politics now even if
even from people who who purport to be
you know you know very radical and very
left-wing they actually want to keep
this the basic structure of society in
place just make it more representative
and I also think that
it's identity has become this like
identity many of the people in my book
many many men particularly in my book
who felt very disenfranchised there was
like an identity crisis going on beyond
things like deprivation and material
poverty it wasn't just me it wasn't just
material poverty there was there was
kind of an identity crisis going on
so to be like a man say several hundred
years ago your identity may have been
defined by safe fighting in a war or you
know not met this isn't as early I'm not
saying this is a positive thing all you
know working in a in a steelworks or a
factory or something
as a producer someone who did things
somebody went on adventures so many made
things someone who even near killed
things
it's against so I provided for their
family yeah and a lot of it revolves
around this the status of providing
supporting children and supporting
supporting your wife etc and then that's
kind of passed away to some extent and
we've kind of said that you know that
doesn't matter because you can derive
your identity from being a consumer so
no longer based on what you produce no
longer based on where you go what you do
who you protect or whatever you support
but now it's just you know your identity
is derived from what you buy and this
has proven you know insufficient for
lots of people people just they're still
people very unsatisfied it doesn't feel
like you know you may be able to dress
or you may bet a dress in the attire of
your favorite celebrity but you've still
got to go back to the your your bad job
the next day you've still got all these
social problems around you et cetera and
but at the same time I think for
middle-class African middle class people
the world of kind of identity politics
that it's all just it kind of in some
ways I sort that I think it's not really
beneficial to them either but I think it
plays into this kind of narcissism
there's narcissism of small differences
so you know I identify as you know you
see people with their with their strap
lines on their Twitter profiles you know
what they identify as and it's just like
like so what so [ __ ] what it's like
it's just this this narcissism of small
differences where you split the
difference is smaller and smaller and
smaller and it's just a form of hyper
individualism what you're separating ups
into smaller and smaller groups which to
me is
is left being left wing as about
universalism is about coming together to
fight for kind of common to come for
common aims and that seems to me to be
the opposite of that it's it's about the
narcissism of small differences about
these ideological wars against all these
different smaller factions whether
you're you know you would you're a turf
or whether you're you're a pro trans or
whether you're um yeah all of it all of
this stuff and it's um it's to me that's
just an extension of near what's called
neoliberal politics this is there's not
really much that's left about that to
him to my mind anyway well I'm offended
typical straight white man punch it down
yeah and poor people who I don't
self-identify as a [ __ ] rabbit or
whatever it is and that sounds you can
hear James is the entire trigonometry
audience standing up and giving you a
standing ovation not big fans of
identity politics on the show but this
is this is the conversation that needs
to be had man because the differences
between the real left and the real right
are much smaller now than the
differences between these woke people
and everyone else because they're
[ __ ] mental they've gone off the deep
end my favorite moments with them this
way know like I said my mother is from
Venezuela and I've had relatives who
were journalists who I speak to and they
go well you know I could disappear at
any moment and they they then come in
and lecture me about Venezuela it's
wonderful and you know and then no way
makes me want to repetier around their
face anyway and on that note I would
totally back you well it'd be the last
ever episode of trigonometry right okay
so with the question that we always
finish with is is the same question do
you want you want to give it content and
yet what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
should be talking about I would say I
mean some of the things we've we've
covered already I would say the kind of
identity crisis particularly among
particularly among men but been saying
that like it's saying that I don't mean
to exclude people from that conversation
it's not a case of so you know you you
have people who talk about this in a way
that does exclude others so I don't it's
not a question of it's you know it's
just white
white working-class men I think there's
a there's generally an identity crisis
in terms of what it means to be be a be
a man in the 21st 21st century I'm gonna
be looking at this in another book in a
forthcoming book at some point what I
hope when I get around to doing that but
it's um I think there's you know if you
look at rates of suicide depression
amongst amongst men in especially
working-class areas those things tend to
be sent to be very high and that debate
tends to be sidelined because you know
because upper-class wealthy white men
have often have done very well in our
society at the expense of other groups
very often particularly women
particularly members of ethnic
minorities and but just just carte
blanche talking about privileged white
men you're kind of it's another way to
give those those people who in terms of
the class system sit at the bottom of
that system giving them another kickin
and I think there's a profound identity
crisis at the moment amongst many young
men particularly in America you see the
rise of these moves they're in sales the
the kind of men's rights movements which
some of that is quite toxic some of that
really does play up to the toxic
masculinity labeled it's apply to it but
you know I'm someone who's on a
socialist Social Democrat socialist
still I like to look at the causes of
these things rather than just saying you
know these are deplorable Zoar bad
people I want to know why people are
gravitating to wars those movements why
there's this big rise in kind of
so-called involuntary syllabus and
people who just feel that they're
completely alienated from say the dating
world from from from members of the
opposite sex from society in general and
I don't think we're I think there's a
big reluctance to talk about that no one
wants to talk about why so just to kind
of finish I guess with with the in cell
say it's it's easy to just talk about
are they're just losers they're just
they're just you know losers who just
can't find a girlfriend can't can't get
laid you know you know whatever and
maybe that's true but why is this why is
this phenomenon happening nighttime
shouldn't we try then to get these
people socialized so they can meet meet
meet members of the opposite or the same
sex you know the program they're men men
men yeah it seems to be a very
dismissive like dismissive attitude
towards people
yeah and I don't think this is healthy -
and again I think that's another of
those things we're just painting it in a
very moralistic thing of there's just
these bad people these deplorable you're
just storing up even more problems for
the future and even more of a backlash
when these people went you know when
when when these people are just left to
kind of rot essentially yeah well is
it's a crisis of meaning because if you
take that meaning away from people they
will find their own meaning one way or
another and if you don't give them
access to meaning that's healthy and
fulfilling and supportive of society
they will find a way to sabotage society
they'll find some kind of meaning or
some kind of group that fights against
whatever is in existence yeah I mean we
see I mean we see this like the rise in
say like like people are attracted to
say Islamism like extremists extremist
kind of Islamist politics leaving the UK
to go and fight for the Islamic state
again it's it's a search for meaning
it's it's it's a it's a search for kind
of meaning in a world where you feel you
feel alienated from in a society for
alienated from in a society where you
feel like you're going through this
existential crisis you can't see any
kind of Mimi - and it's manifested is
something extremely negative there is no
solution the complete solution where you
create the perfect society but you and
you see it again with them but we look
at that I mean we look at that and we
assess why these people are attracted to
this thing but then when it comes to why
people are attracted to say go down this
path of hatred and and you know this
this disillusionment and negativity in
terms of in terms of young young West
like Western men not it's not white it's
not white man is it's it's this a
mixture of of ethnic groups but but
living in the West why they're going
down this this this dark path typically
on the Internet we're very dismissive of
it at least mainstream media is very
dismissive of it and oh you know just
screw them it's their privileged
privileged it doesn't matter but it does
matter and we should yeah we should we
should we should not just let people rot
on the margins because it comes back to
bite us in the end no I agree man five
years from now we could see an army of
in cells just
keyboards on the streets yeah absolutely
crap it fight alright and so thank James
it's genuinely been a wonderful
interview incredibly illuminating if
somebody wants to find you on social
media on Twitter on Instagram where
would they find you so I'm on twitter @
@j underscore Bloodworth and i'm on
instagram @ james Bloodworth instagrams
the more you'll find me more on
instagram nowadays because that's the
more fun side and more silliness more
fun I'm trying to get away from Twitter
can be quite toxic I find whereas my
Instagram friends it's all about just
screwing around and having having fun so
yeah so follow James on that buy his
book hired its it's a great book and
very interesting as you've seen James a
lot of interesting like things to
contribute to this debate as always
follow us at trigger pod on all social
media and we will see you in a week from
now absolutely and please please please
please tell the words subscribe we are
now on bit shoots if you prefer to go on
to bit shooter if that's a platform you
like to use also as well and leave us a
nice review on iTunes it really does
help and thank you very much and we'll
see you next week bye bye
[Music]